this is one of the many giant holes cut
deep into the streets of London 25
meters down hidden from you
this is exploited biggest construction
project the London's say for our
engineers the scale is massive a 100
kilometre rail line cutting through and
under the centre of London when the
trains around every run on this side and
then the platform of B on this side here
the trains will run and the older is
responsible for the Western tunnels at
six foot four even he's dwarfed by the
project this gives you an idea of the
scale of what we're of what we're doing
you know this is our a platform tunnel
platform is 250 metres long Andy is
showing us around what will be the new
on Street Station it's expected to
handle 220,000 passengers a day cross
rails started in 2009 it is now 80
percent complete and on schedule to open
in late 2018 when operating it will
handle 200 million journeys a day
linking Europe's busiest airport he
throw to the shopping mecca of Oxford
Street and the financial hub of Europe
the City of London
tunneling is slow and relentless work
specialist concrete sprayers are
reinforcing the platform tunnel it takes
24 hours to move just four meters
forward so we work 24 hours a day seven
days a week so we've got four four crews
that work eight-hour shifts each other
where they're rotating the crews we have
a Christmas break but we've pretty much
broke through the rest of the year
forty-four million working hours have
been completed on the project and
there's still four years to go until
it's finished but there is one number
British taxpayers won't forget that is
the staggering total cost over 15
billion pounds London is expected to
grow by another 1 million people in the
next decade and Crossrail promises to
keep the city moving Caroline Hyde